rené ce soir c'est vrai que tout le
monde en a parlé et ça a été un
déferlement sur les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup de gens s'en sont pris aux
supporters marseillais
et c'est vrai que ça a été tout le monde
a dit que ça a été une année 6 a même
été condamnée par le président du club
monsieur ayrault qu'est ce que vous
demandez ce soir alors voilà faut mettre
tout comme bart aider les bonnes
discussions
personnellement je peux vous dire que je
condamne ce qui s'est passé et tous les
marseillais connaît ce qui s'est passé
il faut pas dire ouais il y en a que ces
normes
tous les marchés français et tous les
supporters dans le même mois le premier
homme condamné ces violences et qui ont
eu lieu samedi
alors une fois c'est ça c'est ça que
j'ai dit ça que c'est crade et donc
merci maintenant moi 4t au ton pote
largué qui fait le second poteau si
c'était aux voix la série de rédacteurs
gentil m'appeler de ta part tu m'as dit
orné voix et affirment qu'ils voulaient
voir parce que pendant paris ce qui
s'est passé j'ai dit oui tu sais
pourquoi
dis moi parce que depuis samedi jeanne
et pour écouter les grands de
l'information tout tous les discours
sont à charge et des supporters il y en
a pas un qui a donné les raisons de ce
déferlement que je connais ce qu'on peut
les avoir
voilà alors il faut dire une chose c'est
qu'ils étaient 400 supporters
j'ai parlé avec des supporters qui
étaient du jour là ça me dit ils m'ont
dit on et on n'a rien compris nous les
travées les fumigènes et pas de carton
mais riche en terreau démission du pape
au discours on a vu arriver qu'à tous
ces mecs ltd tous deux remporté une
coupe d comme on l'a suivi
voilà ce sont des éléments perturbateurs
qui se sommes intégrés à ses supporters
qui étaient là quand il faut d'habitude
il avait mis c'était merveilleux
il avait mis des pancartes dans tous les
ports de marseille dans toutes les rues
de vente et sur l'autoroute
partout il avait hésité devant la caméra
les fumiers niches étaient si ça c'est
pas si michaël dewitte harvick a toussé
mais je vous tue le bordel